my name is HOD Lipson I'm a associate
professor at mechanical and aerospace
engineering department here at Cornell
University we do research in various
aspects of robotics but we also have
been exploring lots of different new
directions in design and manufacture of
other things which is how we got to this
whole area of 3d printing fab at home is
an open hardware 3d printer and it's the
only 3d printer that can use a wide
variety of materials so you can print
anything from cookies to play-doh to
silicone stainless steel epoxies clay
and anything else your heart can desire
we gave the machine away the designs
away for free online people started
building their own and after they were
done 3d printing with silicone they
decided what other goo do I have laying
around the house and the answer was
peanut butter and Nutella easy cheese we
started using fluid materials initially
as kind of structural support materials
you know we use the frosting as support
material because it dissolves in water
and so forth is a very kind of useful
structural properties then we went on a
little tangent and decided to experiment
with hydrocolloids they're nice fun
materials it's actually the same
materials we use for 3d printing living
tissue which we also do on this machine
we tried to build foods from the ground
up where we would control the texture
with the hydrocolloids flavoring agents
for the flavors and add in vitamin so
you can imagine you know dial in your
hamburger and it also gives you your
lipitor medication and everything you
need and builds a fake hamburger from
the ground up we just forgot one
fundamental rule of cooking which is
that you should cook with food and we
went back to the drawing board and with
the help of chef David Arnold we started
working on modifying traditional foods
anything from cheese and pesto to pasta
to frosting peanut butter chocolate
scallops that we printed in two space
shuttles and deep fried cubes of turkey
with cubes of celery paste on the inside
pear jam breathe Leslie there anything
that you can push through a syringe but
my personal favorite
a new form of deep-fried corn we
developed with chef David Arnold could
you think modern America deep-frying
corn solve problems with 3d printing
anything's possible the fact that you
can print with food at all is still
fascinating for example it's if you can
print a cookie as you've seen that has
vertical text inside there is nothing
new about the materials and those
cookies is still chocolate in vanilla
dough but it's the particular way that
you combine them and the particular
geometry that would take normally would
take a literal chef a skill level of
skill to do that's that's really the
novelty here so usually we don't see new
materials but it's the new ways of
combining them and so forth it'll be in
restaurants it'll be in homes and it'll
be used for automating food preparation
but it'll be used for more than that it
will give you control over your food so
maybe you like cookies that are a little
extra crispy on the outside and be able
to go into your application tell it how
much you want Chris penis you'll
automatically make the cookie the way
you want or you can record grandma's
recipe and how she drew out individual
treats for the family dinner and then a
hundred years from now your great grand
kids can be 3d printing out the same
exact recipe with the same exact motions
this will be a kind of home appliance
that will be it will be difficult to
explain how we live without
you